[Musica]
mi sono molto emozionato nel salire su
questo palco perché esattamente qui
tantissimi anni fa credo ormai più di
una trentina
ho debuttato col mio primo spettacolo si
chiamava la mattanza prodotto dal teatro
crest che tutti voi conoscete e
sì perché io in realtà sono un
imprenditore
ho coniato questo termine mutuandolo da
come noi del crest tutti i lavoratori
del crest cc chiamavano ne facevamo
prevalentemente teatro ragazzi il che
vuol dire che eravamo sempre in giro per
teatri ma anche scuole chiese e cortili
in palestre ovunque si potesse fare
spettacolo d'altra parte il teatro è
ovunque
e quindi nella nostra mattina cominciava
caricando il furgone e tra di noi e
scherzando dicevamo ecco in questo
momento siamo dei caricatori poi eravamo
dei trasportatori e gli smontatori dei
montatori e poi finalmente per quell'ora
ora e mezza che era poi è la nostra vera
ragione di vita eravamo semplicemente
attori
ora io parlo di me ma se qui sul palco
come ci fosse marianese che seduta lì
direbbe esattamente le stesse cose e
oggi parliamo di viaggio e il viaggio il
nostro viaggio insieme è cominciato qui
dietro la realtà in via cavallotti verso
la scuola guida sarrocchi non credo ci
sia più ci sia più però è cominciata
quindi quando avevamo 18 anni sono
passati 37 anni di questo viaggio e per
fortuna noi mai neanche per un momento
abbiamo immaginato la fine di questo
viaggio
attori quindi
attori e come arriviamo poi a fata
morgana fata morgana gelato ad avere una
catena di gelaterie naturale che oggi a
otto negozi a roma 2 a los angeles a
beverly hills
avviene perché in realtà per marianese
il generato è la cosa più importante è
forse più importante di me anzi
sicuramente
lei fa il gelato quando aveva 5 anni
studia il gelato da quando aveva cinque
anni ha sempre parlato di gelato è il
suo vero sogno da bambina era appunto
aprire la gelateria
quindi noi siamo insieme da 37 anni
potete capire st gelateria per me no
e
parliamo di viaggio la nostra
se pensiamo che banalmente il viaggio
più importante la vita che facciamo con
le sue tappe la prima tappa per noi
importante è stato andare a roma come
arriviamo a roma a roma ci arriviamo in
perfetto stile marianese così che
rappresento accade che la rai ne offre
un lavoro e io non sapevo se accettare
perché tra i due io sarei il riflessivo
nella realtà le dice che sono un kakà
dubbi ma io preferisco pensare
riflessivo e quindi accade che decide
lei cosa capita capita che io torno a
taranto dopo un mese e mezzo di tour ne
apro la porta di casa vi troviamo nella
città vecchia del palazzo generini
straordinario e trovo quelle quattro
cose che avevamo inscatolate quindi da
riflessivo appunto ho pensato a uno
strato immediatamente cioè le capacità
economiche erano quelle e invece no le
mie guarda mi fa domani ci trasferiamo a
roma ho preso casa su internet
detto fatto il mattino dopo con un suo
cugino furgone è munito siamo partiti
per roma con tutto quello che avevamo
che nell'ordine era un divanetto da
campeggio pieghevole un tavolo con
quattro serie una rete con un materasso
un televisore e un pc portatile hanno
dimenticato il fornelletto quello da
campeggio diciamo sbarchiamo a roma
tralascio le condizioni della casa in
cui siamo arrivati vi dico solo che per
quindici giorni abbiamo dormito con il
letto con la rete al centro della stanza
stando lontano il più possibile da tutto
quello che ci poteva essere però eravamo
a roma e quindi cominciamo la nostra
avventura
quasi subito però avvengono due cose
importanti
la prima chiudono il programma
classico
la seconda marianese scopro di essere
celiaca avevamo curato qualsiasi cosa
per 20 anni allora parlo del 2000
la celiachia non era così conosciuta e
quindi e diventa un problema
avevamo due grandi problemi uno
economico enorme e l'altro di salute che
fare tornare a taranto tornare quindi
viaggiare al contrario tornare qui nel
porto sicuro era la cosa più facile però
eravamo consapevoli che sarebbe che
l'avremo fatto con un profondo senso di
sconfitta
e se c'è una cosa che marinese non
vogliamo avere sono i rimpianti mai non
vogliamo rimpianti e quindi ci abbiamo
provato ci ha provato con tutte le forze
abbiamo fatto le cose più incredibili ho
lavorato in biblioteca a lei faceva
l'animazione dopo scuola elementare con
i bambini
finché una notte sul famoso divanetto
pieghevole da campeggio lei con laptop
sulle gambe mi dice io apro una
gelateria
risposta nata avuto consta gelateria
cioè non abbiamo una lira
e invece invece aveva trovato questo
bando della regione lazio per
l'imprenditoria femminile
e mi fa la proposta dice proviamoci
allora io
preparo il progetto perché perché prima
di fare l'attore in realtà io avevo
finito gli studi di economia al termine
dei quali una cosa mi era chiarissima
non potevo fare nel commercialista nel
bancario perché anche per quello ci
vuole talento io ne ero completamente
sprovvisto però avevo studiato quindi
preparo il progetto e
ricordo che la mattina in cui siamo
andati presso la banca popolare del
lazio a sapere se il nostro progetto
fosse stato finanziato meno abbiamo
preso un caffè e siamo entrati con tutto
quello che c'era rimasto 40 centesimi è
andata bene ed è partita l'avventura
cosa facciamo oggi marianese ha talmente
studiato il prodotto che in questo
momento siamo l'unico prodotto gelato al
mondo privo di qualsiasi additivo se
chimico che naturale privo di
interessanti privo di coloranti e solo
materia prima cura non abbiamo nessun
tipo di semilavorati per gelateria
facciamo un prodotto praticamente e
naturalmente puro
questo che cosa ha significato
questo modo di produrre il gelato
chiaramente attirato tanta gente a dire
faccia perirono gelateria ma apriamo
giornate via di professione
quindi cosa ho fatto
ho cercato di ho realizzato con il mio
staff
un sistema che potesse aiutare a
replicare questo prodotto in assenza
dell'artigiano capo in buona sostanza
riuscire a fare lo stesso gelato che
mary fa a roma a los angeles
lo abbiamo fatto usando la tecnologia
erroneamente si pensa che la tecnologia
quando portata nel campo
dell'artigianato tenda da flos ad
affossare l'artigiano a farlo
trasformare in industria non è così lo
abbiamo dimostrato
se tu usi l'alta tecnologia al servizio
dell'artigiano gli liberi spazi
organizzativi e anche per la sua
creatività e così noi oggi abbiamo
software assolutamente innovativo e
unico che ci consente di replicare il
nostro gelato in qualsiasi parte del
mondo con la stessa filosofia abbiamo
dei ricettari collegati alle bilanci
ormai sono oltre 400 ricette gli
artigiani che collaborano con maria in
tempo reale realizzano
quello che hanno in mente aiutati da
marianese e quindi cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo lo stesso giocato la stessa
cultura la stessa eticità nel prodotto
la stessa palatabilità si dice texture
non e non vi voglio annoiare
consentendo però agli artigiani in
questo caso parliamo di los angeles
anche di usare la materia prima del
luogo ma di produrre lo stesso tipo di
gelato che c'è a roma
quindi abbiamo gusti identici ma anche
la possibilità di trovare del dei gusti
particolari del luogo
non voglio tediarvi trotto con
meccanismi i meccanismi tecnici quello
che più interessante per me e dire che
molta gente quando ci vede di se sì
siete una coppia ma come fate a lavorare
insieme no
perché spesso si dice con la coppia che
lavora insieme tutto il giorno insieme
la non litigate come fate non vi
sopportate più è la prima risposta
quella tecnica e che veramente noi ci
siamo completamente divisi i compiti lei
si occupa della produzione io mi occupo
di sviluppo marketing
situazione questa e quella tecnica nella
realtà io penso che ci siano due cose
che sono permesso tutto ciò la prima
un po di pudore credo che si chiami
amore
tra di noi
la seconda è la capacità di sorridere
alla vita perché guardate
quando eravamo sul divanetto pieghevole
spesso uno dei due cadeva era veramente
una roba terribile e abbiamo sempre riso
di questo oggi ci possiamo permettere
tutt'altro ma sappiamo che se dovessimo
per qualche motivo tornare indietro e
tornare su quel di vento continueremo a
sorridere perché sappiamo come si fa
ora vi lascio con quello che io in
marinese vogliamo dire ai nostri
concittadini a voi noi siamo di taranto
è quello che vogliamo dirvi è che da
taranto a beverly hills è solo un lungo
salto
basta prendere una grande rincorsa e poi
mai ma proprio mai guardare giù
[Applauso]